One, two, one,. Sorry, bleib. Einen wunderschönen guten Tag, hallo und herzlich willkommen zu dieser neuen Ausgabe von das Podcast UFO, wie immer in der Normalbesetzung mit Stefan. Wurden wir Florentin, Florentin, wurden wir gerade beleidigt? Ja. Oder wurden wir gelobt? Ich glaube, der Linus, der hat sich selbst gesampelt. Linus! Der Linus. Linus 1, muss man tatsächlich sagen, der erste Linus, der jemals Teil dieses Projekts war. Und der letzte, das sage ich jetzt, prophezeie ich, der erste und letzte Linus. Hat dich das so enttäuscht, dass du sagst, mir kommt kein Linus mehr ins Haus? Nee, nee, nee, ganz im Gegenteil. Es war so gut, da kommt auch niemand mehr ran. Kein Linus wird sich mehr trauen, ein Intro einzureichen. Danke Linus für diese vielleicht melancholischen, ungewohnt düsteren, ja fast schon albtraumhaften Klänge, die er hier seinem Instrument entlockt. Samplen ist ja Clown. Samplen ist Clown, das ist korrekt. Und wenn man aber sich selber samplet, ist es noch krassere Kunst, weil man aus sich selber man klaut von sich selber, ist es sehr transzendental, wenn man schafft was Neues aus sich heraus. Das ist der Grund, warum Darth Punk jeden Tag in Angst leben, bei jedem Türklopfer reissen sie zusammen, ist das der Herr Kommissar, der mich endlich verhaftet und dann eines Tages sitzen sie im Gefängnis. Das kann natürlich passieren. Darft, passt auf. Ich habe Darth Punk verstanden. Da dachten wir, das ist der coole Loose Brother von Darth Vader. Ja. Darth Punk. Aber er geht immer noch schön auf die Straße, weil er ist real geblieben. Er ist real geblieben. Er ist real geblieben. Er läuft auf der Straße mit den Leuten im Todsternraum auf der Straße auf der Street. Ich wurde heute von Enten angegangen, so ein bisschen. Oh, okay. Hier vor uns. Ich saß auf einer Bank, ja, saß auf einer Bank. Ich glaube, es sind wieder unsere guten alten Freunde die Canada Geese. Die alten Gänse, ursprünglich aus Kanada stammend mittlerweile. Die sich jetzt bei uns rächen, weil wir die ganzen Canada Goose-Jacken im Winter auftragen. Genau, richtig. Jetzt kommen sie zu uns aus Kanada, um uns die Augen auszustechen. Ja, sie hatten anscheinend irgendeine Rache-Vendetta am Laufen. Sie haben ja auch ein Flugzeug abstürzen lassen, das in der Themse landen musste. Da haben sie sich quasi kamikaze-artig in die Triebwerke hinein geflogen. Sully? Sully, ja. Es ist nicht Agent Sully. Es ist nicht Agent Sully, es ist einfach nur Sully. Aber es wäre ein cooles Crossover. Sully und Agent Sully. Ich kann fliegen, ja, ich kann gut übernatürliche Dinge erforschen. Agent Sully und Bart Simpson landen dieses komische Flugzeug, dann kannst du auch Captain Phillips da drin. Das ist so derjenige, der so 20 Prozent der Geschichte kennt und den Rest so ausfüllt. Ja, die von X-Files, die musste dann nee, die war an Bord oder war es der Mann, Sally war nee, die war an Bord, will nicht jemand anders die Geschichte erzählen, kann nicht also es muss doch jemand im Raum sein. Das finde ich immer so schön, wenn es ein Pärchen wenn Pärchen Geschichte erzählen und dann sagt einer oder sie du erzählst dir besser die Geschichte ich finde das so toll, aber auch ein Arschloch-Move, weil dann immer so du erzäh erzählst die Geschichte so viel besser, Schatz. Ja, ich hatte meinen. Und dann dreht man sich so um und dann ist, Spotlight ist so auf ihm. Okay, also es war im Januar. Nee, lass mich kurz. Und dann gerät die Redstimme immer wieder rein. Aber ich finde es so, es ist so süss auf der einen Seite, dass man dann sagt, ach, mein Freund erzählt diese Geschichte so, so toll, er kann generell toll Geschichten erzählen, tolles Kompliment, aber in dem Moment ist so viel Druck auf ihm drauf, dass man nur versagen kann.
Du darfst in Gesprächen nie irgendeine Art von Metakommentar sagen, nie von wegen, wow, das Gespräch ist gerade interessant, oder wow, wollen wir nicht über was anderes reden, das darf man einfach nicht machen. Nee, das darf man einfach nicht machen.
Wenn man, angenommen, man trifft sich mit Freunden, trinkt was, hat einen schönen Abend und dann sagt man so ab Minute, weiß nicht, 35, oh, das ist ja so ein schöner Abend. Abwärts, Leute, es ist alles ruiniert. Ab dem Moment ist alles vorbei. Oh, habt ihr gerade auch so viel Spaß? Einfach kein Metakommentar, darfst du nicht machen, ist unangenehm. Ich hatte aber mal eine andere Situation, und zwar haben ein Freund von mir und ich, wir haben zusammen eine Doku geschaut, wir haben die gleiche Doku geguckt. Beide sassen vor dem Computer und haben die Doku geguckt über Battle of Hastings. Moment, aber ihr wart in einem Raum? Wir waren in einem Raum, ja. Habt ihr gleichzeitig angemacht auf euren Laptops? Nein, ein, okay, ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass es so viel Zeit kostet, okay, wir haben auf einem Gerät. Ich würde gerne wissen, wie ihr zusammen saßt. Wir haben auf einem Gerät. Weil du auf dem Laptop zeigst. Einer der ersten iMacs, die mit dieser durchsichtigen Schale. Der war verbunden mit dem Internet. Durchsichtig, komplett durchsichtig. Transparent durchaus, aber also. Eher Milchglas. Du konntest ihn dort schon auch sehen. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, das war schon durchsichtig. Ich glaube, es gab mal so eine Zeit in den 90ern, wo alles so durchsichtig sein muss, auch der Game Boy Pocket und so, wo man sagen würde, da ist die Magie drin, guck mal die Dreiete.
und auf jeden Fall der Computer, der war verbunden mit dem Internet,
und über das Internet kam ein Video zu uns über The Battle of Hastings,
eine Schlacht im Mittelalter, die aus irgendwelchen Gründen strategisch besonders ist und so. Und dann haben wir einen dritten Freund getroffen am Tag, in München waren wir zusammen, haben wir einen dritten Freund getroffen, der großer Geschichtsfan ist. Und dann haben wir gesagt, ja, wir haben diese Doku gesehen über Hastings. Und dann hat er gesagt, ah krass, okay, und wie ist das? Und dann hat mein Freund, mit dem ich es zusammen gesehen habe, angefangen zu erzählen, was da so passiert ist. Ja, und dann die im Schlamm und dann die Ritter mit ihren Metallschulen. Und du hast bei jedem Satz gedacht. Und dann musste der Freund, der erzählt hat, aber kurz Geld abheben. Und dann ist er aus der Gruppe gegangen. Und dann dachte ich, damit jetzt nicht so ein merkwürdiges Vakuum entsteht, kann ich ja einfach weiter erzählen, weil ich habe die Doku ja auch gesehen. Genau. Ich weiß ja, was jetzt passiert. Gleichzeitig auf dem transparenten Markt gesehen. Gleichzeitig passiert. Also sage ich, genau, und dann hatten die halt einen Vorteil mit ihren Bogenschützen und dann sagt der Freund, ah nee, wir warten kurz, bis er wieder zurück ist. Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh. Und ich war so, Moment, stopp, pause, pause. Also, ich weiß, du hast keinen guten Ruf, also du hast keinen hohen Wert von mir, ich habe kein hohes Ansehen bei dir. Genau. Aber wir haben exakt die gleiche Doku gesehen. Ja, im gleichen Raum. Im gleichen Raum. Wir haben die gleichen Meinungen schon besprochen. Wir haben uns danach geupdatet wahrscheinlich mit gewissen Meinungen zur Doku. Aber wirklich diese Aussage, nee, ich will es lieber von ihm hören. Nee, genau, lass uns das einfach von ihm erzählen lassen. Was hast du dann gemacht? Dann steilst du daneben und hast einfach gewartet, bis er wieder da ist. Ich meine, ich sehe ein, dass ich nicht die erste Geige bin. Okay? Ich sehe ein, dass ich nicht der Headliner bin. Aber als Lückenfüller
habe ich mich schon
gesehen. Pausenclown. Es ist wie
irgendwie so ein Act, Headliner, Rock am Ring,
Act hat eine technische Panne. Genau.
Und du bist wieder der Tichhüb, der rauskommt
und sagt, wir haben gerade ja so eine technische Plane,
die Band und buh, buh,
nein, wir wollen lieber gar nichts sehen. Die Band kommt
gleich wieder. Wir wollen lieber gar nichts
sehen anstatt dich. Ich will lieber diesen Geldautomaten anstarren. Ja, das ist die Situation, wenn man dann beide so guckt. Ah, jetzt gibt er die Nummer ein. Ja, vor allem du hältst einfach das Gespräch on hold. Geht nicht, kannst du nicht. Ja, das ist auch genau wie du gerade auch mal so ein Metakommentar über die Situation komplett aus dem Leben ballert.
Geht nicht. Ich habe mich nie davon erholt. Ich habe mich nie davon erholt. Und bis heute stehe ich ganz tief unten im Ansehen bei diesem Freund, was historisches Wissen angeht. Wie ging es danach weiter, du und der Freund, der dich on hold gesetzt hat, der offensichtlich nicht an irgendeiner Information aus deinem Mund interessiert ist? Naja, ich sag mal, ich bin ja eher so der Typ, der dann den Fehler bei sich sucht und sagt, ja, krass, der respektiert mich so wenig, dass er nicht denkt, ich könnte dieselbe Doku, die ich gesehen habe, gut zusammenfassen. Vielleicht bin ich das Problem, vielleicht habe ich echt keine Ahnung. Vielleicht bin ich wirklich so schlecht, wie der mich hält. Okay, du hast jetzt hier ein grösseres Publikum. Magst du uns, lieber Florentin, gib mir mal deine Hand, magst du uns vom Battle von Hastings erzählen, hm? Magst du uns heute hier, wir hören dir alle gerne zu, wir lieben dich und wir supporten dich und wir freuen uns auf dich. Okay, meine Chance, meine Chance, fünfzehn Jahre später, alles wieder richtig zurück.
Okay, hier ist deine grosse, Moment, du erzäh, meine Chance, 15 Jahre später, alles wieder richtig zurück.
Okay, hier ist deine grosse, Moment, du erzählst die Geschichte so toll. Ja, also die Franzosen, die hatten dann, die, also die hatten. Werbung. Choro. Choro, ja. Bring nochmal schnell. Werbung rein, kann irgendwer kommen, kann irgendwer übernehmen. Ja, im Bogenschütz, ich weiß auch nicht genau, keine Ahnung. Aber das wäre so lustig, wenn wir jetzt einen Guest, können wir das hinkriegen, dass wir jetzt ein Guest-Star irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, ich frage, Etienne von Rocket Beans oder sowas, irgendwen, der jetzt das Battle von Hastings erzählt und dann schneiden wir das da rein. Das wäre ja eigentlich ganz lustig. In dem Moment, wo du ansetzt, erzählt uns Sophie Passmann das Battle von Hastings. In so einer ganz kurzen Zusammenfassung. Ich glaube, da finden wir historisch begabte Menschen auf jeden Fall kein Problem. Ich finde das sehr lustig eigentlich, so als kleinen Gag im Podcast, Metagag im Podcast. Gerne, Metakommentare sind immer gerne gesehen. Ihr werdet jetzt feststellen, ob wir uns dazu hinreißen haben, diese Arbeit, extra Arbeit reinzubringen. Oder ob das jetzt nur so als Idee hier rumschwebt. Ja, vielleicht bleibt es einfach als Idee im Universum hier rumschweben. Dann sass ich auf der Bank und dann kamen die Enten an. Ja, ach, da war ich. Und dann, aber Enten finde ich ja immer so gut, weil die wollen Brot haben, aber die betteln nicht. Sondern die stellen sich nur so hin und sagen so, na, ich wäre jetzt da. Enten. Enten. Ich wäre jetzt, oder die Gänse in dem Fall. Ich bin jetzt anwesend. Ich wäre jetzt bereit, Brot in Empfang zu nehmen. Mach mit dieser ... Ich lasse das mal im Raum stehen. Mach mit dieser Information, was du möchtest. Ich bin entweder hier oder vielleicht tippst du dich gleich ins Wasser, schwimmen da rum, ich bleibe in der Nähe. Ich bin da, wenn du mich brauchst, Brot loswerden willst, ich bin hier. Genau, ich bin empfänglich. Nee, ich würde es einfach gerne selber essen. Ich würde das Brot einfach. Nee, weil es wirkt so, als ob du wartest. Also ich werde dir das Brot nicht geben. Nee, Ende. Ist alles in Ordnung, alles in Ordnung. Ende, Ende, Ende. Ich will nur sagen, ich habe Angst, dass du gerade irgendwie auf mich wartest, weil du könntest dir woanders vielleicht Brot holen. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, ich stehe hier und. Ich wollte das selber essen. Ich bin Fan von Weltmeisterbrötchen, den Krustenknackern, den Knisterkugeln, den Krummsenkniegeln, den Wellnessbrötchen, den Sixpack, lass dir einen geilen Arsch wachsen, Sixpack-Fitnessbrötchen. Ist auch in Ordnung. Fitnessbrötchen auch einfach. Was ist da drin? Dieses Magnesium, was man so braucht für die Hände? Ich weiß es gar nicht. Steroide, Kreatin, einfach alles da drin. Solange ich bei der Tour de France nicht die Fahrradfahrer sehe, wie die ein Fitnessbrötchen essen, sag ich Bullshit! Nein, nein, we call bullshit. Das Podcast-Projekt sagt Bullshit, Verbraucherhinweis. Bullshit-Alarm, Bullshit-Alarm. Solange ich nicht im Fitnessstudio die Leute mit den dicken Muskeln sehe, wie die zwischen zwei Wiederholungen sich ein Fitness- Wellness-Dinkel reinziehen.
Stopp! Stopp, wir halten an.
Bis hierhin und keinen Schritt weiter.
Nicht mit uns. Ende.
Aber es sind die
Enden sehr nah an einem
Pokémon. Ja. Achtung.
Erste Entwicklungsstufe, Ente.
Zweite Entwicklungsstufe,
ganz. Dritte Entwicklungsstufe, Sch, zweite Entwicklungsstufe Ganz, dritte Entwicklungsstufe Schwan. Ja, tatsächlich. Hals wird länger, Körper wird größer, es ist im Prinzip wirklich einfach eine Entwicklungsstufe. Ja, vor allem, ich meine, die japanischen Entwickler von Pokémon haben diese relativ natürlich offensichtliche Dreierkonstellation gesehen und gesagt, nee, es ist eino-Pokémon. Der ist so ein bisschen bescheuert.
Ja, genau. Wir machen Enten gegenüber immer Kopfschmerzen.
Okay, okay, cool.
Psycho, okay. Und wenn er sich
weiterentwickelt, dann wird das so ein Psycho-Schwan,
der so michtig krass mit so grossen
Flügeln, vielleicht dann so
Malereien innerhalb, dass er so aussieht,
als könnte er so Illusionen, so Rorschach-mässig,
dass er so Innenflügeln und sowas hat?
Nee, er wird noch mehr Kopfschmerzen. Enteron. Enteron? Ich bin ehrlich gesagt nicht bewandelt genug für dieses Bit. Ich weiß nicht, wie ich weiß nicht genau. Ehrlich gesagt kann er auch genau so aussehen, wie du es gerade bist. Wasserstein-Pokémon. Weiß ich gar nicht genau. Keine Ahnung. Theorie, ich hatte eine Theorie zu Pokémon.
Und zwar gibt es ja das, gibt es ja Pikachu, ne, Ash hat Pikachu, Ash liebt Pikachu über alles. Pikachu wird besser, besser, besser, stärker, stärker, stärker, Level steigen, Pikachu spürt in sich diesen Drang, inzwischen bin ich eigentlich ein Raichu, er will sich entwickeln. Und Ash sagt, nein, nein, nein, nein, hier, nimm das und mach dem Mondstein ins Müsli, weiß ich nicht, jetzt fehlt mir hier die Information über die Lore, aber er gibt dem Mondstein, damit er sich nicht weiterentwickeln kann. Richtig? Und er immer sein Pikachu bleibt. Nicht ganz korrekt, aber ja. Okay, du hast literally Kopfschmerzen, Enton-artige Kopfschmerzen. Und deswegen dachte ich, vielleicht haben wir es hier mit dem Münchhausen-Stellvertreter-Symptomen zu tun. Er vergiftet für sein eigenes Wohl Pikachu. Ja, er will den Kleinhalten. Er will den Kleinhalten unter sich halten, eine Abhängigkeitsstruktur erstellen. Und haben wir es hier quasi in diesem harmlosen Anime mit Münchhausen-Stellvertreter zu tun. Das kann ich mir sehr gut vorstellen, ja, auf jeden Fall. Aber jetzt lag ja die Grundlage, war jetzt falsch. Du hast ja Kopfschmerzen bekommen. Vor allem, ich meine, wir haben ja den Smetbo-Fall, also wir haben ja die Patientenhistorie, dass ja damals in der Jugend der Smetbo-Fall kam, der zu mächtig wurde und Escher den ziehen gelassen. Also vielleicht ist er unfähig, die Macht der Pokémon wirklich dadurch zu ertragen, wenn sie Gefahr läuft, seine eigene Macht zu überschreiten. Okay, aber dann würde ich sagen, wir haben das mit Narzissmus zu tun. Weiter? Wenn er nicht ertragen kann, dass Pokémon unter ihm wachsen, sondern er will die klein halten, damit er der grosse Krasse ist. Der Trainer darf nie irgendwie in Schatten gestellt werden von einem zu starken Pokémon oder sowas. Da könnte es ja das Pokémon sein, was die Erfolge erzielt und nicht mehr Ash. Ash, Ash, Ash. Fucking narzisstisches Arschlochkind. Vor allem ein zwölfjähriger Junge. Was hat er auch für eine Beziehung zu diesem Professor? Ei, alles ist merkwürdig daran. Ich glaube, es liegt auch insgesamt an der Mutter. Klar, alleinerziehend, wissen wir nicht. Wo ist der Vater? Genau. Auf Montage. Wir wissen nicht genau, wo der Vater ist. Mutter ist nicht einfach, klar, aber ein einziges Kind. Aber trotzdem, dann ist er am Start, aber dafür, dass er so klein ist, läuft er sehr viel in hohem Gras rum, wo Monster mit Attacken existieren. Kleines Stichwort an der Stelle, Zecke. Wird nie erwähnt, hohes Gras ist extrem gefährlich, Zecken leben da. Ich glaube, niemand hat so sehr von Pokémon profitiert wie die gemeine Zecke, wo das einfach herschahrend von Kinder durch die sohe Gras gelaufen sind und die Zecken einfach so, what the fuck is this heaven? Ich kann mich gar nicht entscheiden. Joey, is this heaven? Aber jetzt, sorry, noch mal ganz kurz, also es ist der Donnerstein, nicht Mondstein und der entwickelt sich zu Reitschuh, wenn man Donnerstein nimmt und ich ich glaube, Pikachu möchte es nicht, deswegen macht es Ash nicht. Aber eine Zecke, die hängt also an ihrem Grasheim dran und wartet, dass jemand vorbeiläuft. Das heißt, angenommen, ein Hund läuft jetzt durchs Gras und läuft so ein Meter an der Zecke vorbei und die Zecke so. Oh, fuck! Fuck!
Fuck! Du bist so ein Versager. Fuck! Ich stelle mir vor, dass da so ein Trainer steht mit so ganz vielen kleinen Zecken und der so sagt, so Jungs, da werden wir trainiert. So, here we go. Da hinten kommt der Hund, okay, er ist schnell. Wie ist die Aufstellung? Aufstellung ist Frederik auf der Eins, Per auf der Zwei, Moncler auf der Drei, Jean-Pierre auf der Vier. Aber Trainer, da wurde ich schon wieder auf der Vier. Halt deine dumme Klappe, Jean-Pierre. Ach, wie mehr muss ich hin denn stehen? Wladislaw auf der Fünf. Sie? Mhm. Und Swane auf der Sechs. Ahne auf der sechs okay okay und henry auf der sieben so und die stehen wir stehen alle und dann sagt er hat er so ein triller pfeife im mund die fahrtpapa trainer zecke und dann kommt der hund vorbei und er sagt go go go und dann wie so fallschirmspringer ich glaube die können auch weit springen springen, ich weiß nicht, nicht flo weit, aber weit. Okay, kleiner Diss an der Stelle, nicht so weit wie in Flo. Gut, wir sind nicht mehr Flo, aber wir sind besser als der Mensch. Aber so, also ich meine, die können jetzt nicht vier Meter weit springen, die müssen schon grob sich da in Lauer legen. Ich glaube, die müssen in Lauer legen haben. Und dann gibt es ja auch bestimmt viele Zecken, wo einfach nie jemand vorbeiläuft, oder? Also die einfach komplett falsch sich aufgestellt haben, die einfach falsch die Zeichen gelesen haben, die gesagt haben, jetzt Bubble Tea, jetzt setze ich mich hier hin und es kommt einfach niemand vorbei. Ja, aber das ist das, wie ich oft am Invisible Bar-Syndrom leide, wenn man irgendwo, weiß ich nicht, an einer Bar ist oder so im Club und man geht zur Bar und man sucht sich genau den Ort aus, wo niemand jemals hinkommt. Und man steht da eine halbe Stunde und denkt sich, was ist das, ist das mein Leben, ich will nach Hause und tutschgucken. Dann versucht man so krampfhaft irgendwie so Blickkontakt zu halten mit den Leuten. Man will aber auch nicht zu verzweifelt wirken. Nee, aber das Gesicht fällt irgendwann ein in diesem So weird, das ist dann super schlimm. Man fühlt sich dann so ungesehen und egal. Ja, und genau so geht es der Zecke auch. Ich meine, die ist den kompletten Grashalm hochgelaufen, bis sie irgendwann sagt, das ist so genau das gleiche, wenn du vom Zehn-Meter-Turm wieder runtergehst. Das ist genau der gleiche Climb of Shame, den die Zecke macht mit so einem Ach weiss er was, komm. Mit so einem, er hat so einen Aktenkoffer dabei und dann kommt er wieder nach Hause. Schatz, wie warst du auf der Arbeit? Ach, frag nicht. Oh mein Gott. Ich dachte, wenn ich mich jetzt da wieder direkt neben dem grossen Busch hinstelle, ist es heute ein guter Tag, aber nichts kam gar nichts. Hey, ist doch alles gut, ist doch kein Problem, okay? Wir sind für dich da, die ganze Familie ist für dich da. Ja, ich weiß nicht, es hilft mir wirklich, aber ich würde gerne mal wieder was. Was hat doch mal dein Arzt gesagt? Es ist eine momentane schwierige Situation für dich, es ist ein momentanes Loch, da kann man einfach wieder raus. Trotzdem haben wir gedacht, vielleicht solltest du dir mal Hilfe suchen nochmal oder irgendwie versetzen lassen oder so. Das ist nur eine aktuelle Sache. Ich glaube, wenn ich mich wieder zu der grossen Eiche hinstelle, ich glaube, das ist ein guter Platz. Ich glaube nur, weil wir müssen ja die Familie auch irgendwie ernähren und so und langsam kommen wir an die Grenzen.
Also ich bin gerade der Einzige hier, die regelmässig Blut nach Hause bringt.
Ja, ich weiss. So, das musst du mir jetzt auch nicht jeden Tag sagen.
Ich weiss, ich will sie ja auch gar nicht unter die Nase binden. Ich meine nur, es ist halt nicht einfach.
Weil wir Zecken sind, sagst du unter die Nase binden?
Genau, ich will sie nicht unter die Nase binden. Ich weiss nicht, wie unsere Anatomie aussieht.
Nee, das war völlig korrekt für uns.
Ich will sie nicht unter unsere Kiemen reiben. Okay, alles klar. Wir kriegen das hin. Gut, mach dir keinen Horn drauf. Strenge dich ein bisschen an. Lass uns kurz unter sieben Augen sprechen. Eine ungerade Zahl. Ich habe bewusst eine ungerade Zahl gewählt. Ich weiß nicht, was es aus Zecken macht.
Und ich meine, selbst wenn er dann irgendwann
was trifft, wird er einfach
60 Kilometer weit weggetragen
und sieht seine Frau nie wieder.
Spannend.
Weil einfach die Zecke hängt da und die Zecke
ist das fucking bad-ass-Tier der Welt.
Das ist einfach offen
für alles. Einfach, pass auf,
hier kommt ein Hund, let's fucking go! I'm riding that thing. Ist es ein Besen, ist es eine Jacke, ist es ein Hund, scheißegal, das ist jetzt mein Ding. Und dann einfach wachst du auf, in Ungarn, und denkst dir, gibt's hier überhaupt Zähne, kann ich mich hier paaren, ist hieraren? Aber ey, da hinten kommt irgendwas an und dann wieder so und dann wirklich wie so. Wie Tramper der Natur einfach. Egal wohin, für mich hin, egal. Der Horizont ist meine Heimat. Nur weg von hier, hauptsache weg von hier. Das ist, finde ich, total spannend, was du jetzt gerade kreiert hast. Zecken waren für mich immer das Hasstier Nummer eins. Wahnsinnig gefährlich hochstilisiert in der Schule. Nehmt euch in Acht vor Zecken. Meningitis, holy shit, du wirst sterben an Zeckenbissen. Zecken sind die grösste Angst da draußen. Macht die Türen zu, da draußen sind Zecken. Schwärme von Zecken. Das war so gross gemacht, bei den Fahrtfühlen zumindest auch immer. Anti-Zecken-Spray, Zecken, wir untersuchen uns alle nach Zecken, zieh dich aus Stefan, zieh dich bis auf die Unterhose aus, zieh alles auf den Spiegel. Leg dich da hin, zieh alles aus. Nee, komm, du musst noch mehr ausziehen. Alles, auch das. Und dann Zecken untersuchen. Es war immer ein unheimlich präsentes Thema. Und gerade hast du es geschafft, zum ersten Mal die gut zu konnotieren. Als geile, Abenteuerlustige, ich nehme das Abenteuer an, ich gehe da raus, ich sage Ja zum Leben, ich sage Ja zur Reise, fuck alles, was hinter mir liegt, ich nehme diesen Hund und ich reite den bis an den Horizont. Ich beiße da rein, egal was es ist, und ich sauge mich komplett voll. Und scheiße, nein, es ist doch wirklich ein Besen. Und dann beißt sie da rein und denkt sich, naja, okay, jetzt sterbe ich in 20 Minuten, weil wir leben nicht so lang und alles, was ich gemacht habe, ist an diesem Besen zum Nuckeln. Aber das ist das Risiko, dass eine Zecke eingeht. Das ist die wundervolle Natur. Die Welt der Zecke. Wunderbar. Ich schaue jetzt auch gerade wieder Prehistoric Planet 2. Warum kommt dir das so schwer über die Lippen? Warum kommt dir das so schwer über die grossen T-Rex-Lippen? Weil es mich bedrückt. Okay. Das ist eine Dokuserie über Dinosaurier, wo diese einfach so tun, als wäre das eine Naturdoku, aber die Dinosaurier sind halt animiert einfach. Ich liebe das alles. Und es ist immer cool, weil die Folge ist immer so in zwei Teile geteilt. Der erste Teil ist so den klassischen Doku, so, ah, hier sehen sie den Ercoropteryx und er baut sein Nest und so, und du denkst dir, nee, das ist alles Bullshit, das habt ihr euch alles einfach nur ausgedacht. Und dann kommt aber der zweite Teil der Folge, wo du die Wissenschaftler siehst und die Paläontologen und die dann die Fossilien zeigen und du denkst, na, ich will wieder die Dinos sehen. Nicht so ganz zufrieden. Und jetzt in der letzten Folge war es aber besonders dramatisch, weil da ging es um diese Ammoniden, Ammonitas-Dinger. Spoiler. Ja, okay, sorry, wer noch nicht durch ist mit der Staffel, hört jetzt weg, sorry. Diese grossen Schnecken mit den Tentakel dran haben. Und dann gibt es diese klassischen wie auch das Pokémon Ammonitas, wo du diesen Wirbel hast, diese Schnecke. Und dann schwimmt es da so raus und so und dann siehst du noch andere Varianten davon. Und zwar einer hat so dieses Hornteil, also dieses Schneckengehäuse, aber nicht eingerollt, sondern ganz lang. Einfach wie so eine Mainzelmännchen Zipfelmütze, so ganz lang. Und du denkst dir, what? Aber es passt, finde ich, zu diesem Dino-Feeling, dieses, wir sind noch nicht ganz fertig, wir haben es noch nicht ganz gecheckt. Das ist ein großer Testrun, wir haben Dinge hier, das ist wie ein AI, eigentlich ist die Evolution, habe ich schon mal verglichen, aber wenn man so erste Gehversuche von so AIs sieht, die irgendwie ein Spiel überwinden müssen oder sowas, die kommen erstmal auf mehr komische Ideen.
Und so wirkt tatsächlich die Natur auch, weil natürlich auch die AI die ganze Zeit Trial and Error, Trial and Error und immer das nimmt, was am besten funktioniert, wird weiter benutzt und die Natur geht ja im Prinzip einen ähnlichen Weg, immer.
Man probiert Dinge aus und dann werden die aber nicht, pflanzen die nicht fort, weil what the fuck ist das, Riesenspitze, die nicht eingesetzt werden kann, das sieht aus wie ein lustiger großer Hut, das sieht einfach aus wie kleine Elfen, die durchs Wasser schwimmen und so. Das war so, sorry, blöd, blöd, ich hab's einfach mal so gesagt, sorry, nee, war eine dumme Idee, ist ja okay, alles gut, ist ja gut, alles in Ordnung, weg damit und weh, alles okay, passt schon, weg damit. Und die versuchen es einfach aus, die versuchen es aus. Aber es ist auch so, wenn man so in die mittelalterliche Medizin schaut, wo man denkt so, ach süss, also das ist so, ja, wir nehmen Blut ab und Säfte und ja, das, und du denkst dir so, ja, hier und da Ansätze, aber nee, Kollege, nee. Aber die haben das ja ultra ernst genommen, die waren ja genauso wie heute Ärzte, dass die sagen, wir nehmen das super ernst, wir sind Wissenschaftler. Glaubst du? Na, ganz interessante Frage. Interessante Frage. Also wir haben keine Ahnung, also Sie können jetzt dieses, nehmen Sie dieses Blatt, ich verschreibe Ihnen dieses Blatt. Okay, ja, okay, wenn Sie das sagen. Ich habe keine Ahnung warum, und scheiße, ich weiß nicht. Okay, das ist besser als nichts, ich meine die Alternative an der Pest sterben. Ich mein, ich hab's ... Wie eine gesamte Familie. Sie können's nicht nehmen, und vielleicht hast du das gleiche Ergebnis, aber es hat mal jemand genommen und der wurde dann von der gleichen Krankheit, die sie hatten, geheilt. Super, perfekt. Und keine Ahnung, ob es damit zusammenhängt und so, aber nehmen sie es einfach. Und dann so, wie viel muss ich davon nehmen? Keine Ahnung, also sie können das nehmen, ich hab noch zehn davon da, Sie können zwei nehmen, Sie können acht nehmen oder fünf.
Oh, werter Herr Kollegus, interessant, ein anderer Medikus. Sag mal, hast du auch gar keinen Plan, was du machst? Ich habe keine Ahnung, ich bin vor der Polizei weggelaufen und dann lag hier dieser Kommissar weggelaufen und dann habe ich mir diesen weissen Mantel übergezogen, weil mich nicht mehr erkennt. Und seitdem bin ich in diesem Raum, Leute kommen zu mir und wollen Diagnosen, aber ich habe keine Ahnung von nichts, ich weiß nicht, ich verscheide nichts, ich verscheide nichts, ich verscheide dem Wasser. Ich bin eigentlich Doktor der Literaturwissenschaften, ich habe keine Ahnung von Medizin, aber die Leute reden mich an mit Doktor und jetzt denke ich mir, ich habe null Plan, gar nichts, überhaupt nichts. Ich freue mich, wie ich kennenzulernen. Ich bin Herr Globuli. Sehr schön, freut mich. Ich verschreibe den Leuten so kleine Zuckerkügelchen. Ah, okay, sehr gut. Und ich sage denen, dass es genau das bringt, dass es genau das ist, was sie brauchen. Hey, auch nicht dümmer als meine Ideen. Ja, ich habe so diese kleinen, merkwürdigen Blutegel. Ah ja, nice. Einfach drauflegen oder was, damit ich aussaugen? Fuck it, fuck it, fuck it. Ja, im Zweifel weniger Blut. Was soll passieren? Hau rein, hau rein und dann so ein Ritter-Handschlag. Gab es Polizei im Mittelalter? Nee, es war dann die Stadtgarde. Das ist umstrittenes Thema, aber es ist ein interessantes Thema. Warum ist das ein umstrittenes Thema? Weil das natürlich oft immer so dargestellt wird, dass jemand Schlägerei und dann kommen sofort Leute und lösen die auf, aber wer ist das? Stadtgarde. Stadt, ja, aber weiss man auch nicht genau. Ich weiss auch nicht genau. Ist natürlich ein Thema, das einen im Rollenspiel ständig begleitet, weil die Helden ja ständig irgendwie Schabernack treiben und du denkst, irgendjemand muss das aufhalten. Aber wenn du genau darüber nachdenkst, denkst du dir, weiss ich nicht, vielleicht auch nicht, keine Ahnung, weiss man nicht noch. Aber der Burgherr hat ja kein Interesse daran, dass Unruhen in seiner Stadt existieren. Also wahrscheinlich hat er so eine militärische Organisation. Aber stellt dir dann Leute ab, die patrouillieren oder nicht? So am Tor, glaube ich, sind immer so Leute, die dann sagen so, Herr, hier, komm rein oder nicht. Hast du das richtige Lösungswort? Hast du die richtigen Schuhe an? Hast du die Schuhe an? Nee, mit weissen Stegen kommst du hier nicht rein. Ich finde, das ist immer so eine Situation. Also du kennst ja so die Situation. Burg Martenstein. Du kennst ja die Situation. Es gibt Türen. Markwart, dammit. Es gibt Türen und manche können rein, manche nicht. Manche haben Schlüssel, manche müssen reingebuzzert werden von außen. Und jetzt die klassische Situation, du hast einen Schlüssel von der Tür, gehst an die Tür und da wartet gerade jemand, der keinen Schlüssel hat, der gerade geklingelt hat und reinbuzzern will, Post hat oder so. Und dann gehst du und machst die Tür auf und dann geht der mit dir rein. Und ich hab immer so ein, wir haben Fremdkörper jetzt zu Hause. Eigentlich hast du ja noch nicht den Punkt erreicht.
Du hast den Chip, du hast den Schlüssel,
gehst rein. Verstehe mich nicht falsch,
im Leben würde ich niemals sagen, geh nicht rein.
Aber es ist so ein ...
Du weißt eigentlich, du hast noch nicht den Status,
dass du eigentlich zur Tür rein darfst.
Genau. Richtig.
Das ist ein komischer Moment.
Und viele Leute bleiben nur noch draußen und sagen so, ich habe noch nicht, ich habe noch nicht das, kommen Sie rein, Das ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, noch draußen und sagen so, ich habe noch nicht das Kommen Sie rein, das Herr Rhein. Und dann denke ich immer, das sind Vampire. Die müssen nämlich rein gebeten werden. Gilt das als Einladung? Nee, Rheinbassern gilt als Einladung, glaube ich. Das muss halt der grosse Kongress von Transilvanien 2008 klären, aber die sind zum Schluss gekommen, dass reinbuzzern eine Form der Einladung.
Naja, so weiss denn der hereinbuzzernde, wen er da herein holt. Sir, es ist ganz klar, die Antwort liegt auf der Hand. Es ist ganz einfach, ein reinbuzzern heisst, hallo, kommen Sie herein, besuchen Sie mich. Nein, aber nicht wenn die Person es nicht ihm direkt ausgesprochen wird.
Ein Beispiel, Herr Werther-Kollegos, ein Beispiel. Ich komme an eine Tür und sage, ich bin Lieferando, Ihre leckere Pizza ist hier, leckere Pizza. Lassen Sie mich doch herein und ich werde hereingebuzzert. Knoblauch-Pizza? So hat die Person nicht mich reingebuzzert, sondern eigentlich eine andere Person und somit habe nicht ich die Einladung bekommen. Wenn du sagst, hier ist Graf Kripkenstein von der alten Kripkenburg und der buzzert dich dann rein, dann haben wir kein Problem. Wir müssen sicher sein, dass wir gemeint sind. Das ist klar. Das ist klar. Sicher.
Bazar muss für uns bestimmt sein. Das ist ganz klar. Darüber reden wir nicht, werte Kollegen. Das ist nicht Thema hier. Transsilvanien-Kongress 2008. Nein, das ist nicht Thema. Thema ist Basar als Signal für uns Einladung. Ich sag ja. Basar, wenn es unter dem richtigen Kontext geschieht, ist das kein Problem. Es kann nur ein Kampf entscheiden. Es kann nur ein Kampf zwischen Valerie Krippgenstein. Also das ist doch diese Art archaischen Methoden müssen wir doch. Immer der eine Vollidiot, der immer einen Kampf fordert. Ein Kampf muss entscheiden, bei The Lords, by The Ladies. Wie fucking faul man damals auch war einfach.
Ja, eigentlich ist es der Münzwurf in bisschen zu krass gedacht eigentlich. Lass die Münze werfen, da müssen wir nicht, da müssen wir nicht, da müssen Leute nicht sterben, weil es eine Entscheidung her muss. Hätte man auch machen können, so das Duell, wo man dann sagt, ja Gott führt die Hand des Gewinners und dann wird so das Gottesurteil gesprochen. Aber man sagt ja auch, dass es so schnellalte, also wenn man eine Entscheidung treffen muss und man wirft eine Münze, hilft es einem ja auch schon manchmal zu wissen, wohin man eigentlich tendiert, weil man ja schon für eine Seite hofft ein bisschen. Manchmal ist es zumindest der Fall. Warst du jemals dir so klar in etwas, dass du zum Beispiel im Mittelalter für diese Entscheidung oder für diese Meinung gekämpft hättest? Ach so. Ich glaube, ich habe noch nie in meinem Leben, weil ich denke mir jedes Mal, ja, andere Alternative ist auch bestimmt ganz toll. Ja, bestimmt, ja. Ich kann mich so schnell entscheiden. Ich bin nur ein vierminütiges Video-Essay davon entfernt, genau die andere Meinung zu haben. Oder ich bin eine Folge weiter in der True Crime-Serie davon entfernt, die andere Meinung zu haben und für den auf die Strasse zu gehen. Genau, das ist wirklich interessant und ich glaube, ich war noch nie in meinem Leben,
ich weiß so wenig, was ich denke, actually, dass ich ernsthaft für etwas kämpfen würde.
Ja, man sagt heute, die Gesellschaft ist so polarisiert und alle haben starke Meinungen,
aber nee, damals hast du dich duelliert und einfach bist gestorben. Du hast gesagt, das ist mir jetzt so wichtig, dass ich sterbe.
Du warst eine andere Meinung und deswegen kämpfst du gegen den Schwarzen Ritter.
Ja. Wo kommen die überall her überhaupt? Warum ist hier alles voller Schwarzer Ritter?
Diese fucking Flat Earthen Schwarzen Ritter, ey. Die ständig in unkonstruktiven Diskussionen enden, wo dann einer stirbt.
Da ist schon wieder einer. Oh nee.
Man ist abgeschossen, weil es dann die Pistole immer irgendwann kam. Das war wahrscheinlich einfach ein Game Changer.
Das war ein guter Move, ja. Game Changer, ja, ja, ja, ja. Schwarzpulver, ne? Ganz, ganz heikle Sache. Geht montags, und hört mich auf, hört mir kurz zu, hört mich, lass mich ausreden, hey, geht montags morgens nicht zum Zahnarzt. Das lassen wir kurz stehen.
Das ist etwas, was ich am Wochenende gelernt habe und ich bin sehr stolz darauf. Ich komme aus einer Heizungsanitärfamilie und lasst euch sagen, geht montags morgens nicht zum Zahnarzt. Kannst du dir vorstellen, warum? Das ist wirklich ... Das hat mich jetzt rausgebracht. Ich stamme aus einer Heizungssanitär-Dynastie und geht nicht, weil da die Heizung noch nicht an ist und es noch kalt ist, oder was? Nein. Weil, du musst dich vorstellen. Wasser. Genau. Das Wasser steht das ganze Wochenende. Das Wasser steht das ganze Wochenende. Niemand, kein Zahnarzt ist am Wochenende ja da. Sagen wir mal, dann machen die auch Freitagsfrühfeierabend, ne? Ich meine Zahnärzt. Am I right, am I right? Am I right, am I right. Brückentag. Brückentag, oh noch schlimmer, oh Gott, oh Gott, oh Gott. Und man sagt tatsächlich, dass wenn zwei Tage das Wasser in den Leitungen steht, bilden sich Legionellen. Die Chance ist sehr gross, dass sich Legionellen bilden, kleine Legionellen. Und die können dich tatsächlich umbringen. Das ist der grösste Gegner, die grössten Rivalen der Heizungsanitärfamilien. Und der Germanen auch. Und der Germanen, die haben lange gegen die Legionellen gekämpft. In Teutoburger Wald gibt es ja, also die, wir haben dann das, also die Überbleibsel der Germanen haben dann das Hermannsdenkmal gemalt, das riesengroße Denkmal. Da sagst du wir. Nee, habe ich mich jetzt versprochen. Aber finde ich gut, wenn du einfach klar Seite beziehst. Als die Rebellen gegen das Imperium gekämpften, da hatten wir grosse Verluste. Ja, genau. Wer bist du? Na, kann man ja heutzutage nicht mehr sagen, sage ich. Und die Legionellen haben auch ein Kunstwerk, also ein ganz kleines Statue gemalt. Und das heisst, du hattest jetzt schmutziges Wasser im Mund? Genau, und wenn man dann zum Zahnarzt geht morgens und hat den ersten Termin, werden literally in deinem Mund die Leitungen ausgespült. Mit wahrscheinlich Legionellen. Und deswegen, also das ist auch lustig, weil meine Familie ist interessant, wenn man nämlich aus dem Urlaub kommt, machen die überall erstmal die Wasserhähne auf, weil damit erstmal muss es durchlaufen. Wie lange musst du den Wasserhahn auflassen? Drei Minuten, um sicher zu sein. Drei Minuten? Habe ich auch gefragt sofort. Fand ich zu lang. Ich glaube, es ist übertrieben. Was ist das denn für eine krasse Leitung? Also der Teil der Leitung, der zu deinem Haus führt, hält Wasser, dass du drei das ist schon krass. Nee, ich glaube, nee, nee, in deinem in deiner, die Leitung in deiner Wohnung, da steht einfach Wasser drin. Da steht davor wird ja so viel abgezweigt, da ist ja immer in Bewegung und sowas, kommt immer neues Wasser durch, aber wenn du zwei Wochen Urlaub warst oder sowas, sollte man daraus, das habe ich noch nie gemacht, ich habe immer direkt daraus getrunken oder so was, sollte man wirklich nicht machen. Stehendes Wasser ist super gefährlich, es sterben Leute daran, das erzählen sich alle Leute da in dieser Heizungsanitärwelt. Und ich fand das interessant und habe dann gedacht, weil das kam aus dem Nichts, hat mein Onkel diesen Effekt getroppt, geht morgens, montags morgens nicht zum Zahnarzt. Ich dachte mir, das ist ein Unsinn. Das ist so, wie Anthony Bauderner gesagt hat, Donnerstags bitte kein Fisch essen, weil da ist er noch nicht, da ist er nicht mehr frisch. Okay, gib uns einen Zeitplan. Ich mag die Vorstellung, wie du beim Zahnarzt liegst und dann ich muss noch kurz was holen und du so pfff, einfach auf, Wasser auf. Was machen Sie hier? Drei Minuten lang, drei Minuten lang.
Sie fällt mich nicht davon ab. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, drei, noch zweieinhalb. Dann kriegst du eine Spritze, eine Beruhigungsspritze in den Arsch. Ich bin aber tatsächlich gerade in einer ähnlichen Situation, weil, viele wissen es ja schon, aber um es auch hier im Podcast nochmal zu sagen, ich bin bald im Urlaub. Ah, okay. Da bin ich ja schön im Urlaub. Ja. Und natürlich, ich glaube, meine Aktivität allgemein ist das gesamte Jahr über vergleichsweise niedrig unterm Durchschnitt. Ja, definitiv. Ausser in den zwei Wochen vorm Urlaub. Da zieht's hoch. Da sage ich, okay, pass auf, ich brauche ärztliche Untersuchungen, ich brauche Zahnarztterminen, ich brauche irgendwie... Um frischen Kiefer zu haben, was hast du vor im Urlaub? Ich muss meine Konten in Ordnung bringen, ich muss irgendwie Geld anlegen, damit vor dem Urlaub alles in Ordnung ist. Was hast du im Urlaub? Ah, okay. Warum muss dein Kiefer gut ausgestattet sein? Weil ich bin da so ein bisschen fernab der Zivilisation. Das heisst, wenn ich im Urlaub plötzlich Zahnschmerzen kriege, Ende. Ende, Urlaub, Ende. Und ich mag meinen Urlaub sehr gerne, ich freue mich da drauf und deswegen will ich nicht dann in der Situation sein, wo ich sage, soll ich jetzt da irgendwie irgendwo hinfahren im Zug um Zahnarzt, deswegen muss alles tip top sein vor dem Urlaub. Verstehe ich. Und, ähm, ich weiss nicht, ob du es weisst, aber ich bezeichne mich ja selbst als Halbmensch, Halbmaschine. Ich bin verdrahtet, ich habe Draht im Mund.
Ja, habe ich auch.
Und der Retainer, ja, also ich hatte lange eine Zahnspange, jetzt Retainer für alle Uneingeweihten, für alle Uneingeweihten, es ist ein Stück Draht, der vorne, der hinten an den Zähnen ist und da festgeklebt ist. So und vor ein paar Wochen ist ein Zahn da abgegangen, also der ist so an vier Zähnen drangeklebt und an einem Zahn ist er abgegangen. Und das ist natürlich... Und vielleicht habt ihr es sogar, wenn ihr aufmerksam wart, gehört im Podcast, weil man natürlich zwangsläufig immer schön mit der Zunge und ich habe das einfach ruhen lassen, weil fuck it, kein Bock. Und jetzt kommt aber mein Urlaub und deswegen habe ich gesagt, letzte Woche Keyfiefer-Tobelden-Termin, let's go, harte Fakten. Termin war angesetzt, 15 Uhr, dann hat sich alles nochmal ein bisschen verschoben, also habe ich den Termin verschoben auf 16 Uhr. Dann bin ich da hingefahren, habe erstens ewig keinen Parkplatz gefunden und dann war das eines dieser Gebäude, die einfach keinen Eingang haben, keinen Ausgang haben, einfach so ein einfach geschlossener, aus einem Stück geschmiedeter Obsidianblock. Ja, wie so ein Monolith, wo du drum rumläufst, die auch ganz merkwürdige Geometrie haben, wo du irgendwie, das ist ein Quader, aber dann fünf Seiten, wenn du rumläufst. Da möchte ich einwerfen, dass ich schade finde, dass Städte nicht aussehen wie so Comic-Versionen von Städten, wo der Zahnarzt, das Haus des Zahnarztes ist dann so ein grosser Zahn oder so, weiß ich nicht, die Polizei ist dann sehr erkennbar, weil ganz gross Polizei draufsteht, ein grosses Wappen oder so eine Knarre oder sowas. Dann eine grosse Spritze für den Arzt, einfach du weißt genau, was los ist. Genau, vorne so eine grosse Spritze und oben dieses Lichtding oben noch drauf und so was. Genau. Genau, eine große Bierflasche ist dann so eine Taverne. Ich bin es wissensschade, dass Städte haben sich nicht dahin entwickelt. Man muss immer Double-Tag, um es herauszufinden, was ist. Genau, es sieht alles gleich aus, es ist alles super schwer. Und dann bist du in diesem merkwürdigen, museumsartigen Gebäude, marmoriert irgendwie. Genau. Keine Ahnung, was da ist. Und dann ging es schon mal so richtig schlecht los an der Rezeption, wo ich meinte, ja, ich hatte einen Termin auf 15 Uhr, aber ich habe den jetzt auch mal auf 16 Uhr verschoben. Ich weiß nicht, ob das bei Ihnen angekommen ist überhaupt im System. Und dann meinte sie so, ja, ja, habe ich hier 16 Uhr, aber es ist ja auch schon 16.20 Uhr. Äh, ja. Ja, das ist korrekt. Das ist mir ein bisschen unpünktlich beim Arzt. Weil ich den Eingang nicht gefunden habe, weil ich erst keinen Parkplatz gefunden habe und dann habe ich den Eingang nicht gefunden. Und ich wollte nicht sagen, ja, ich habe den Eingang nicht gefunden, weil das auch dumm klingt, diese dumme Ausrede. Unser Haus sieht aus wie ein grosser Zahn und vorne ist eine grosse Tür. Ja, aber es sind vier gleiche Seiten. Ja, es sind die vier Weisheitszähne. Magnus, Mercurius, Ben und Maurice. Es sind die grossen Weisheitszähne, die sind die Gründer der modernen Zahnmedizin. Wieso haben Sie den Eingang nicht gefunden? Jetzt zu der anderen Frage. Wieso haben Sie den Eingang nicht gefunden? Jetzt ist es schon 16.30 Uhr, es tut mir leid. Und dann musste ich, dann hat sie mir so ein iPad gegeben, und dann musste ich so einen ewig langen Anamnesebogen ausfüllen, also lächerlich lang, ich saß da mit meinem Rucksack, musste ich dann ausfüllen, immer wie viele Geschlechtskrankheiten hatten sie schon, wo, was, genau, mit wem, wie, wann, welcher Partei gehören sie an, waren sie jemals, sind sie auf einem Foto mit viele Castro zu sehen. Wofür stehen sie? Beschreiben sich selbst in 20 Sätzen, also hunderte Sachen, ich sass da bestimmt noch mal weitere zehn Minuten da. Was ist ihre grösste Leidenschaft? Nee, nee, ich bin an Anamneseboden, da muss ich mich ernst nehmen da muss ich mich ernst nehmen. Ja, Hockey, Feldhockey. Wenn ja, falls Feldhockey, warum? Falls nicht Feldhockey, warum nicht? Und was dann? Falls Marionettenbauer, warum? Und ich fülle den aus, es dauert ewig, und dann gebe ich den Anamnesebogen ab, also den iPad ab und dann hier nochmal einen Zettel, nochmal Zettel und dann meint sie so, ja okay, gut, dann schauen wir jetzt mal in den Raum. So, ultraschlechte Stimmung, ich setze mich hin und sie so, ja hatten Sie schon mal eine Zahnbehandlung? Ich so, ja ich hatte schon eine Zahnspange, ich habe eigentlich schon alles fertig, bei mir ist nur ein Retainer abgegangen. Und sie, ach so, nee, sowas machen wir hier nicht. Okay, dann, ähm. Aber du hast wirklich, du bist so ein Arztanfänger. Dann gehe ich wieder, tschüss. Ich bin direkt sofort aufgestanden. Ach so, okay, alles klar, dann gehe ich. Tschüss, also wirklich, ah okay, alles klar, mein Fehler, tschüss. Sofort rausgegangen. Was für ein verlorener Tag. Riesige Zeitverschwendung, Termin verschoben, ewig lang Anamnesium hochgedrückt.
Du hast gesagt, 16.20 Uhr hast du gesagt. Ja. Das heißt, der Tag, der Termin lag am Nachmittag. Ja. Wie ich mich kenne und wahrscheinlich du auch, wenn so ein Termin am Nachmittag ist, ist der ganze Tag belastet. Der Tag kennt man ja, manchmal reicht so ein Tropf von Öl, um das ganze Wasser kaputt zu machen. Alles in die Liebe. Und so ist bei mir auch ein kleiner fünf Minuten Call, irgendwie am Abend oder Nachmittag, verfärbt den Tag zu einem schwarzen, grossen, dunklen Fleck in meiner Woche. Vor allem das Ding ist ja, du denkst dir, okay, Arzttermin macht den Tag kaputt, alles vor dem Arzttermin ist ruiniert, aber dafür ist der Rest des Tages nach dem Arzttermin super, weil du hast endlich diese Last vom Herzen und nicht bei dir, denn es war alles komplett umsonst und ich musste wieder rausfinden und es war richtig unangenehm. Und das ist aber auch das Ding mit diesen Online-Terminen, dass du oft gar nicht sagen kannst, was du überhaupt brauchst. So, weil ich würde, und ich würde jederzeit dieses Erlebnis wählen, anstatt anzurufen. Das ist für mich das Schlimmste, was es gibt. Immer nur Online-Termin, aber du läufst halt Gefahr, dass du beim völlig falschen Arzt auftauchst, mit dem völlig falschen Anliegen, die sagen, nee, so was machen wir nicht. Und deswegen absolut furchtbar. Und jetzt habe ich heute den nächsten Termin. Ich meine, ich habe dabei hier ... Wir haben literally Montag. What the fuck?
Ich hab dir gerade zehn Minuten lang erklärt,
warum du montags nicht
zum Zahnarzt gehen solltest.
Das sagst du mir jetzt, das darfst du mir doch nicht montags
sagen. Du musst mir freitags
bis 16 Uhr sagen, was ich montag
früh nicht machen darf. Du darfst heute nicht,
das hab ich mir vorgenommen. Ich bin jetzt
Hardliner. Ich hab jetzt den Termin schon.
Nein, du kannst nicht, dann sag die, die sollen erst drei Minuten vor den Augen die Leitung durchspülen. Im Ernst, im Ernst. Du lässt die da durchspülen. Ist da überhaupt Wasser beim Kiefer zu werden? Ich weiß es nicht. Natürlich, die schleifen ja erst diese Reste vom Retainer unten ab. Hast du jetzt auch noch Zahnprobleme? Bei allen Sachen, die ich in meinem Körper beschreibe, die nehmen immer diese Gäste, dieses ekelige Augen zu halten und wegdrehen. Und dann schleifen die das ab, da kriegst du dann so ein Wasserding in deinen Mund gehalten, damit das schön weggespringt wird. Der Termin ist aber nicht so früh morgens für Erf. Ich glaube, das passt schon. Also geht auf jeden Fall nicht, das habe ich mir auch geschrieben, mein Onkel hat gesagt, geht nicht vor elf Montagmorgen zum Zahnarzt. Du kriegst das noch hin. Du kriegst das noch hin, du kommst den Nachmittagstermin.
Und natürlich immer die Frage, wie sieht das aus mit Mundhygiene? Ich habe extra Zahnbürste und Zahnpasta dabei, gehe jetzt gleich noch hier auf die Toilette und putze mir die Zähne. Ja. Glaube ich, ausserhalb meiner Wohnung habe ich mir noch nie die Zähne geputzt. Ich fühle sich falsch an. Sag mal, es fühlt sich völlig falsch an, aber es fühlt sich auch falsch an, mit schönem Brezelmund zum Kieferorthopäden zu gehen, der dann auch irgendwie einen halben Zimtwuppi dir irgendwie da schön aus dem Retainer rauskramt. Nee, das mache ich auch nicht. Deswegen furchtbar. Ich muss mir auch mal sagen, also diese Attitüde von Kieferorthopäden stößt mir mittlerweile auch ein wenig sauer auf. Nee, das machen wir nicht. Wir sind die Architekten des Mundes. Sie würden doch auch keinen Architekten rufen, wenn bei ihnen eine Glasscheibe kaputt gehen würde. Wir kümmern uns nicht um diese kleinen Sachen. Und dann kommt ein Patient raus, macht den und lächelt so und du siehst so ein wunderschönes Architekturbau im Mund. Ja, perfekt. So, perfekte Zähne, Bauhaus-Style, so eine kleine eingerichtete Familie, wirkliche Karies-Familie da drin. Oh, wow, Style follows Function, perfekt, ich kann da gut leben. Ja. Ich denke mir, Kieferorthopäden, euer Handwerk ist drücken. Ihr drückt Dinge. Ihr seid Handwerker. Euer Mittel der Wahl ist drücken. Ihr drückt die Zähne dahin, wo sie hinwollen. Ihr seid keine Genies, die Architekturbüros leiten, die irgendwelche perfekten, genialen Ideen haben, wenn ihr sagt, ah, der Zahn ist ein bisschen zu weit links.
Du pass auf, wir drücken den nach rechts. Wir drücken den so lange nach rechts, bis er da bleibt. Genial, wow! Also da muss ich echt mal sagen, ich finde, Kieferorthopäden, es sind nicht, also ich finde diese, weil wenn man über Zahnarzt, Kieferorthopäden denkt, dann sind Kieferorthopäden schon so ein bisschen die krasseren oder so. Highbrows, ja. So ein Zahnarzt ist einfach wie so ein Gossen-Typ mit einem Hammer irgendwie, der dir einfach die schwarzen Zähne raushämmert. Aber der Kieferorthopäde so, oh, Draht und Gummi und so. Aber letzten Endes, da wird einfach nur gedrückt. Was würden die machen? Und dann wären sie ja wirklich krass. Sie müssen den verschieben. Sie müssen den ausbuddeln und an einen Ort verschieben. Aber was die Natur denen exakt erlaubt, ist, man verschiebt es so lange, bis es da einfach bleibt. Aber wir drücken ihn einfach in die Richtung und dann bleibt er so, für immer. Und falls nicht, dann machen die den Retainer. Der ist noch ein bisschen, da verstehe ich auch nicht, wie das funktioniert. Zähne mache ich mir keine Gedanken, weil wenn irgendwann sind die ruiniert und dann lasst man sich die abschleifen, dann kriegt man neue Zähne drauf und es ist alles egal. Ja, die werden dann so runter auf so kleine Mini-Hubbeln nur noch runtergeschliffen und dann werden darauf ja dann die neuen Zähne draufgesetzt. Finde ich völlig okay, finde ich völlig okay, so Jürgen Klopp-mäßig, danach ein perfektes Gebiss, alles neue Zähne, dann ist einer von denen kaputt, ah, ich krieg einen neuen Zahn draufgeschraubt. Perfekt! Zähne sind gehandelt, Zähne sind durchgespielt.
Ja, meinst du? Das einzige, was nicht durchgespielt ist, ist Zahnfleisch. Zahnfleisch ist der eigentliche Faktor. Wenn du da Probleme hast, dann ist es durch. Das heißt ja so, das wächst nicht richtig nach, irgendwie so und so und das ist ganz furchtbar. Also da glaube ich, wieder die Glocke, der Heilige Geist ist wieder eingezogen, jedes Mal zum genau richtigen Zeitpunkt. Wir beten alle für ein gesundes Zahnfleisch. Bitte falle die Hände für ein kleines Gebet. Lieber Gott, wir danken dir für unser gesundes Zahnfleisch, auch wenn es manchmal wehtut oder zwickt. Wir danken dir weniger dafür, dass es gar nicht nachwächst. Also da auch mal als Kritik. Nein, da wollen wir konstruktive Kritik äussern. Das war nix. Und wenn man in ein härteres Brötchen beißt, wow, kann das wehtun. Oh ja. Auch hier möchten wir sagen, vielleicht ist da noch ein bisschen Optimierungspotential, lieber Gott. Aber du bist allmächtig. Du weisst, was du tust. Ja, gut, es wäre natürlich auch einfacher, wenn die Zähne einfach von Anfang an immer richtig gerade werden und nicht kreuz und quer. Und du hast uns nach deinem Ebenbild erschaffen. Das heißt, vielleicht hast du nicht genau die gleichen Erfahrungen gemacht, die wir mit Zahnfleisch machen,
nämlich es nervt schon sehr, was alles schiefgehen kann mit einem Gebiss und schiefen Zähnen.
Und warum brauchen die Zähne Nerven?
Also muss es wehtun, weil, also kann man nicht einfach sagen, die sind wie so Fingernägel, die einfach nur mitmachen, die einfach nur arbeitsgerecht sind und gar nicht jetzt Nerven haben?
Und wieso wachsen die nie nach, nur einmal, dann haben wir Milchchzähne, die müssen ausfallen, können wir das nicht skippen? Ja. Sonst Und nochmal zum Penus. Sonst war alles super, vielen Dank, liebe Grüße, liebe Grüße auch an Jesus. Grüße an Petrus, was macht der alte Lappen eigentlich noch, oder? Was macht der eigentlich? Petrus. Der alte Pappenheimer. Der alte Pappkamerator. Oh, apropos Pappenheimer, wir haben ja letzte Woche, vorletzte Woche, ich erinnere mich an nichts, irgendwann haben wir mal über Oppenheimer gesprochen. Der neue Film von Christopher Nolan. Pappenheimer! Naja, aber jedenfalls kommt ja, und da ist das Internet sehr stolz drauf, Barbie, der Barbie-Film, der Greta-Gurick-Film,
und Oppenheimer am gleichen Tag raus.
Wir sind alle ganz aufgeregt.
Da gibt es auch einen schmissigen Hashtag dafür.
Weiß ich nicht genau, wie der heißt.
Bobbenheim, Barbieheimer.
Barbieheimer, naja.
Oppi.
Und die Idee war erst,
alle gehen erst in Barbie, haben eine gute Zeit,
freuen sich, gehen danach am gleichen Tag Double Feature in Oppenheimer,
geben sich die richtige Kost.
Also es ist ... Alle gehen erst in Barbie, haben eine gute Zeit, freuen sich, gehen danach am gleichen Tag Double Feature in Oppenheimer, geben sich die richtige Kost.
Also Barbie so ein Luftholen für Oppenheimer, man guckt an Oppenheimer, geht dann abends nach Hause und schläft selig ein.
Und dann hat jemand getwittert, das fand ich supergut, nein.
Und das mache ich jetzt, der Freundeskreis bespricht den Tag, es ist ein grosses Event, wir gehen morgens elf Uhr in Oppenheimer. Einmal Wasserhähne auf, auch im Kino. Macht die Wasserhähne voll auf im Kino. Lass die drei Minuten lang laufen, dann ist gut, wenn der Montag morgens in Oppenheimer geht. So, danach wird gebruncht und dann steigt man schon so langsam in so ein Sektfrühstück ein. Also man verdaut quasi, man spricht noch ein bisschen über Oppenheimer.
Genau, spricht man da über Atombomben, über Waffen, über Technologie, die Gefahren der Wissenschaft. Erst bei der Vorspeise und bei der vielleicht, ne, dann isst man Brunch ein bisschen, aber dann, und dann kommt so langsam kommen die Mimosas. Mimosas ist Sekt mit Orangensaft oder auch schon irgendwie so ein bisschen Sekt. Auf jeden Fall, es wird dann schon so ein bisschen tipsy. Und man arbeitet sich mit diesem Intellektuellen, wir verarbeiten Oppenheimer Brunch, arbeitet man sich so langsam vor in so einen tipsy, wir haben Bock auf Barbie-Brunch. Es wird immer cheerfuler. Unten nach oben. Jetzt sieht die Anoraks aus von der Morgenkälte, darunter farbenfrohe Barbie-artige Kleidung. So, dann arbeitet man sich vor und guckt dann Barbie, um danach feiern zu gehen. Von Atombombe zu Bombenstimmung. Bombenstimmung, genau, das ist die Transition. Also, morgens elf Uhr Oppenheimer, Brunch, Mimosas, Tipsy werden, Barbie gucken, wo man schon ein paar Lampen an hat, um dann rauszugehen, feiern gehen und eine fabulous night haben. Das ist der Oppenheimer Barbie-Tag. Und der wurde jetzt begründet, der ist clever, der ist so komplett perfekt durchdacht, ihr braucht da keine Gedanken mehr verschwenden, das ist die perfekte Idee. Alle Varianten wurden durchgerechnet, alle beide, und ihr könnt sich erinnern, dass die richtige, und das machen wir, und ich freue mich da sehr drauf. Stark. Ist perfekt. Wann gab's das mal, dass man... Dass Filme so perfekt zusammenpassen auch. Früher gab's das bestimmt mal, dass irgendwie zwei riesigen Filme, riesen tolle, erwartungsvolle Dinge am gleichen Tag herauskamen und sowas. Lange nicht mehr, ich freue mich sehr darauf. Barbie und Oppenheimer an einem Tag. Geil. Und dann, ja, The Fabulous, Fabulous Night. Ich freue mich auch, ich werde Oppenheimer auch anschauen, wenn ich dann wieder für meinen Urlaub so ein bisschen in Heimat bin, übrigens keine Angst, es wird keine Sommerpause geben, wir ziehen durch, aber das auf jeden Fall, da freue ich mich auch, den nochmal anzuschauen, weil ich gehe kaum noch ins Kino, aber dafür lasse ich mich dann doch nicht lumpen, sag ich mal. Finde ich auch, finde ich völlig richtig, man muss es auch dann richtig durchziehen. Ordentlich Nolan-Filme muss man auf der grossen Leinwand gucken.
Aber ich bin auch ehrlich gesagt so, ich sag immer allen, es ist so toll
wie Tarantino und Nolan drehen, alle noch
analog und es ist so geil. Und dann gucke ich
die Filme auf meinem Laptop, auf meinem Schoss.
Schon auf dem Handy im ICE.
Ja, genau. Einfach schön mit schlechtem Internet.
Genau, so 360p gucke ich dann da.
Aber dann immer bei jeder Gelegenheit
zwei Bierintos, ich direkt wieder, es ist so geil, die anderen noch analog drehen. Ach, just shut up, Stefan, halt deine Klappe, halt deine dumme Klappe, red nicht davon, du weißt auch nichts davon, warum ist es besser, analog zu drehen, das ist nicht besser, du kannst alles genau so emulieren, halt einfach dein, das ist mein innerer Monolog, halt einfach deine Klappe, trink dein, Während du alleine an der Bar stehst und darauf wartest, dass dich jemand bemerkt und tu einfach ein komplettes Gespräch in deinem Kopf. Mit dem Kopf dreht sich alles und man denkt ... Es ist analog. Was sie wollen, was sie wollen. Genau, es kommt dann so ein Munchie, kommt der so ... Was willst du zu trinken? Ah, Ich nehme nur ein stilles Wasser.
Ich glaube, ich gehe halt früh ins Bett.
Okay, du musst mir deine Lebensgeschichte erzählen.
Shut up, shut up.
Und dann fängt der Barkeeper auch an, das zu sagen.
Sorry, sorry.
Ja, kennt ihr das nicht?
Manchmal so ein Self-Loathing-Monolog.
Ja, klar.
Natürlich.
Kennt ihr das nicht auch, selbst das? Ich meine, das eine ist ja noch, wenn du, sag ich mal, dich verachtest im Gespräch mit anderen. Was anderes ist, wenn man sich verachtet dafür, wie man war, als man aufgenommen wurde von einer Kamera. Das ist natürlich nochmal was anderes, wenn man sich diesen Moment nicht nur in seinem Kopf immer wieder durchspielen kann, sondern es einfach auch der YouTube-Algorithmus ist, einem einfach regelmäßig wieder vor die Nase sitzt und man sagt, ach ja, stimmt, ach ja, das war ja die Situation. Da war ich ja ganz unangenehm. Sprichst du da aus einer eigenen Erfahrung? Ach na ja, ich habe da mit vielen Leuten aus der Branche, Branche geredet. Branche geredet. Branche geredet. Branche geredet. Ja, sehr gut. Ich überlege mir, alte Bücher zu kaufen, um Geheimnisse darin zu finden, die noch niemand gefunden hat. Alte Bücher, in alten Büchern versuchst du Geheimnisse, wenn die noch niemand gefunden hat. Weil du glaubst, diese Bücher hat noch niemand gelesen, also der hat noch niemand gelesen, oder glaubst du, da er handschriftlich geheimnisvoll eingeschrieben. Weil ich glaube, dass wir heute mit unserem modernen Blickwinkel, mit der modernen Technik Dinge finden, also ganz klassisch, einfach mal durchgehen, die ersten Buchstaben jeder Zeile. Hat jemand mal Shakespeare einfach mal durchgeguckt? Ich glaube, da hast du jetzt den einen ausgesucht, bei dem alles geprüft wurde, rückwärts lesen, oben nach unten lesen, die Buchstaben nach dicke sortieren, ja. So, kann man da nicht was machen, kann man da nicht was finden? Ich glaube, Bibel und Shakespeare brauchst du nicht untersuchen, da wurde, glaube ich, schon alles untersucht. Ich glaube, alle anderen Sachen sind spannend, ja, finde ich gut. Ich weiß nicht, ich habe auch jetzt wieder hier die neuen Pforten gesehen mit Johnny Depp, da wo der so ein Buch hat. Also, weirder Film, aber hat mich trotzdem begeistert. Einfach so dieses, machen Film über ein Buch, dann hat man das Buch und dann guckt das Buch an und man sagt, boah, da ist aber noch mehr in dem Buch, oder nicht? Ja, was ist das für ein Buch? Und dann hat er das auch immer so in der Hand, das ist so ein extrem teures, die Idee ist, dass es ein Buch ist, das er vielleicht der Teufel geschrieben hat und jemand will, dass er das erforscht und er hat das aber immer so in der Hand einfach und steckt das so in die Tasche und gar nicht mit so Samthandschuhen, sondern immer nur so normal. Und ich war eher immer so, oh, Leute, da ist ein Kaffee. Oh, Leute, passt bitte ein bisschen auf. Oh, jetzt raucht der da während er das Buch liest. Das war eigentlich eher mein Film, wo ich dachte, Vorsicht, bitte, Vorsicht. Ich war jetzt am Wochenende auch wieder in meiner Heimat und meine Mom hat von ihrer Oma irgendwie noch so eine Mappe gehabt, wo so alte Bilder drin waren und unter anderem auch ein Magazin, das Magazin Die Woche aus dem Jahr 1928. Wow. Das Geburtsjahr meiner Oma, glaube ich. Und da, aus dem Geburtsjahr, sogar vor dem Geburtsdatum eine Zeitung. Und dann habe ich gefragt, weil das sieht super cool aus und wahnsinnig alte Werbung mit drin und so was, ganz, ganz toll. Kann ich das mitnehmen? Hätte ich gerne zu Hause, kann man sich auch aufhängen oder so was. Ja klar, ne mit. Und dann habe ich diese, und die war komplett erhalten, weil die immer in so einer grossen Mappe eingeklemmt war. Und dann habe ich die in meinen Rucksack gesteckt. Weil ich nichts anderes hatte, um die mitzunehmen.
Und weil die passt auch nicht.
Und dann habe ich dann mal die, aber so eine hundert Jahre alte Zeitung.
Und ich dachte, jetzt stecke ich die in meinen Rucksack.
Hundert Jahre lang war die gut erhalten.
Und jetzt habe ich die in meinem Schulrucksack.
Das ist ja auch nicht, deswegen verstehe ich, das ist etwas, was man immer mit Samthandschuhen anfassen sollte, was man dann so in den Kofferraum legen sollte. Ja, man bräuchte eigentlich immer so Folien, wie wie so Sammelkarten, so Pokémonkarten, immer so Sleeves, wo du die reinsteckst, dass du einfach für alles sowas parat hast. Aber du siehst auch aus wie ein Serienkiller, wenn du immer deine weissen Samthandschuhe anhast oder wie ein Zauberer. Das stimmt auch. Oder wie Mickey Mouse, also irgendwo auf der Skala ist man immer. Irgendwo auf der Skala, ja. Von Leuten mit weissen Samthandschuhen. Sagst du Mickey Maus? Warum sagst du Mickey Maus? Mickey Maus? Nee, Mickey Maus. Nee, Mickey Maus. Nee. Na, ist ja eine Maus. Das weiss man aber schon, deswegen muss man Mickey betonen. Ich will wissen, wie die Maus heisst. Dass es eine Maus ist, ist es allen klar. Ist allen klar. Die grossen Ohren. Nein, aber es ist ja die Mickey Maus. Genau, Mickey Maus. Also die Maus. Ich würde sagen, das wichtigere Wort ist Maus. Und Mickey ist nur, das verändert nur das, was danach kommt. Das ist nur das Adjektive. Das ist ja spannend. Und dann sagst du Daisy Maus. Ist die Daisy Maus. Aber Daisy ist doch Duck. Daisy Duck. Die Daisy Duck. Wie heißt es doch mal? Ach, Minnie, Minnie. Donald Duck. Nee,. Nee, Minnie Mouse. Du sagst ja auch Donald Duck und nicht Donald Duck. Sagst du Minnie Mouse oder sagst du Minnie Mouse? Minnie Mouse. Ah, okay, da ist der Vorname wichtig. Nee, Minnie Mouse. Ja, okay. Vielleicht muss ich da nochmal in mich gehen, vielleicht habe ich da wirklich unterschiedliche Herangehensweisen. Danke, dass du es sagst. Gerne, und ich finde gut, dass wir aufmerksam gemacht hast. Das ist so schön, dass wir hier zusammen kommen zusammen, dass wir gemeinsam zu neuen kommunizieren, dass wir uns nicht ins Wort fallen, sondern gemeinsam an einem Strang hängen, dass wir uns zuhören. Niemand ist wichtiger als der andere,ören und dass wir wissen, dass man alleine nicht so viel über sich selbst erfahren kann wie mit anderen.
Ich freue mich, jede Woche hier in der ersten Reihe zu sitzen und zu hören, was du sagst.
Und deswegen vielen, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören und wir hören uns nächste Woche wieder, wenn das Ganze weitergeht, mit einer neuen Folge des Podcast UFO. Vielen, vielen Dank nochmal an Linus, der uns das Intro zur Verfügung gestellt hat.
Und dann heben wir ab, düdel-düdel-düdel-düdel-düdel-düdel-düdel-düdel-düdel-düdel-düdel-düdel-düdel-düdel-düdel-düdel-düdel-düdel-düdel-düdel-düdel-düdel-düdel-düdel-düdel-düdel-düdel-düdel-düdel-düdel-düdel-düdel-düdel-düdel-düdel-düdel-düdel-düdel-düdel-düdel-düdel-düdel-düdel-düdel-düdel-düdel-düdel-düdel-düdel-düdel-düdel-düdel-düdel-düdel-düdel-düdel-düdel-düdel-düdel-düdel-düdel-düdel-düdel-düdel-düdel-düdel-düdel-düdel-düdel-düdel-düdel-düdel-düdel-düdel-düdel-düdel-düdel-dü.
It's a worst-but-production crack!